if you allow this thing to grow
unchecked it will destroy everything it
will make the NHS unaffordable we will
lose it we'll make education
unaffordable we will lose it it will
make housing unaffordable and we will
lose it and this is not a UK specific
problem you know we've been getting a
lot of messages from America lately and
what do they say every single one of
them says the same thing it's the same
in the USA or Australia even you know
Australia was considered a very wealthy
country right every single one of these
messages is the same thing it's the same
thing it's the same thing and
you know at the same time
you know the government wants to sell
it's because the foreigners because of
brexit it's an international problem
International problem and you're not
going to fix it by voting these people
out right in the end you need to demand
a reduction of inequality and you need
to say I'm not going to vote for anyone
that doesn't give us a reduction in
wealth inequality you know listen if you
know okay I've been quite critical of
the conservatives on this channel if
they're able to turn around and convince
me really convince me that they were
going to reduce wealth and quality I
would vote for them and I would tell the
viewers to vote for them
because that is what matters what
matters is that you kill this cancer